you spend most of your life teaching
people how to argue and debate yeah
because hezbollah's methodology was
ideological propaganda
um we we trained people in uh in idle in
some of the tactics you saw uh During
the covid period which we can come to uh
weren't new to me at all uh we would
train people in in in the methods of
dissemination of ideas for the purposes
of ideological Warfare
um and that's why we were put in jail
because that was deemed very dangerous
our our purpose was to recruit army
officers uh and to eventually convince
them to instigate military coups did you
succeed I've recruited a few army
officers yeah yeah in Pakistan and uh
and um mainly in Pakistan actually the
the people I spoke to at